[Music]
i rule
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos
and today i bring you
a street level superhero
or anti-hero that gets confused
with a dc character that they have
really nothing in common
i bring you today xm studios
moon night now i know a lot of you guys
aren't familiar with moon knight
and hold on
i'm getting ahead of myself let's let's
go back to
when i first you know uh met the
character
i think it was um because i used to read
a lot of
uh street level uh heroes you know like
daredevil
iron fist power man uh
heroes of that nature so
i'm we're reading a book called uh wolf
by night
and i forget what episode is it probably
31 or 32.
uh moon knight attacks
wolf by night and he captures him right
and i'm like yo who's this character
you know he jumps out all white he has
the knuckles and
the like brass knuckles and he he's
fighting him
and i was super intrigued by the
character and he was different
like the next issue where you find out
he was a mercenary
uh hired to capture the the
the wolf the werewolf by night and um
he happened to be uh uh
anti-hero with a heart a mercenary with
a heart
they teamed up together and they
actually you know beat the cabal
uh that was actually looking to capture
the wolf by night and um
i guess marvel figured out they had
something in this character
and they proceeded to place them in
different books
and give them a backstory well
moon knight is the avatar or the
hand of vengeance of khanshu
kanshu is the moon's uh
the egyptian moon god and that's
this face here this is his um
and i will have a picture up but this is
kanchu's
face that they use inside the comic
books
i don't ask me why but actually i do
know why
they gave it to him as a separate
portrait
um so moon knight is
the most misunderstood character that's
in
marvel's history and i don't think they
really know what to do with the
character see
i keep up with the books um now i buy
a graphic novels and i read them that
way
uh opposed to buying single books
because you know they're super up out of
price you know five dollars a book
i come from ten cents a comic books five
cents a comic book two cents a comic
book
so you know five dollars a book is out
of control
i rather just buy the whole story so
over the years uh moon knight
powers suits and
uh mental stability yes i said mental
stability
ranged depending on who was writing him
so traditionally mooney
gets stronger as the full moon goes up
or
as as the moon goes he's stronger at
night
and they're always confusing with batman
he
he actually has powers batman doesn't
have any and the only reason why they
confuse him with batman
is because you know uh mark spector
his secret identity is uh a rich
guy but he's a rich mercenary so you
know you get that whole playboy image
guy with gadgets and he fights crime
well nothing the same he wears all white
and silver
but sometimes the suit has gold uh hands
on it like on the armbands the legs and
the um
the waistband uh batman
is uh black sometimes wearing blue
so nowhere close uh and batman
i think is a far superior fighter but
this is where
they kind of differ because uh moon
knight
has over 10 different personalities he
suffers from multiple personality
disorder
uh as a displacement and
a lot of them think that he is out of
his mind a lot of them think that he
imagines his god can't you
and that's truly not the case
well when dc i mean when
when disney announced disney plus
announced
their uh the shows that were coming out
that was slated
i probably was the only person that
screamed in a crowd than when i heard
moon knight
because he's one of my favorite
characters and i've always read every
book
so his powers like i said he gets
stronger
as the the moon is up uh i think they
had retconned that but they brought it
back
for this new series that they doing
in the new avengers or the avengers
called
uh the age of kanchu and that's where
moon knight goes and he takes the powers
from all
the powerful beings like the iron fist
the aya akamatu from
doctor strange thor's hammer uh
the black panther's blood uh the star
brand ghost riders powers
uh the spirit of engines and the phoenix
force
so yeah he goes and he does this
when i knew that his fighting skills
were are were
far greater than i actually thought
is when he fought uh iron fist
head up and
that kind of took me aback because iron
fist is if not the number one the number
two
best fighter inside the marvel universe
we're probably uh sun she uh being
either number one or number two so when
he beat him straight up and took the
iron fist from him
that kind of surprised me his suit is
made of anti-mattium
or sometimes carbonadium he has uh
different weapons that he employed and
this is where the trickery comes in
because people might assume that
he's of batman's ilk he throws
moon crescent like batarangs which is in
the switch out hand
he also has a larger moon
type of batarang that he throws that's
switching this switch out hand
he also employs a bow staff
like this which is in this switch out
piece but this also breaks down and
turns into a nunchuck
where he actually knows martial arts
now all that is separated into different
personalities
these different personalities are the
personalities that
know these fighting styles and that
actually can do different things so
that's where he's very different from
their average hero anti-hero and
definitely
completely 100 different from batman the
one
uh drastically
different uh aspect from him in batman
is he actually has powers
along with the money so let's get into
the statue
now i know you guys remember when i told
you on dolph castle
x show open mic 9 pm on fridays
uh i told you that i was in line to get
xm
uh studios moon night and the guy kind
of jerked me out of the deal
so along comes uh my man ray
and he's in our statue groups and he
linked me in a sale and he asked me if i
was still looking for the moonlight
and i said of course brother i am 100
on board for this i wanted this statue
ever since that's always available i'm
so happy
that xm does statues of street level
characters like daredevil iron fist moon
knight
and characters of that elk hawkeye so
we set up the deal and he came through
for the kid
i am so happy so when i got the statue i
did the unboxing that you guys was gonna
check
out and i've noticed he had a ton of
switch-out pieces
and i thought that was amazing because
i'm going to
have him how he's displayed right now
with his uh grappling hook that is made
of antimatter
uh and his his fists with um
the brass knuckles the cape is a molded
cape
his face is menacing he's on top of an
egyptian type of gargoyle
representing the sun god ra uh
he's egyptian so you know that kind of
speaks
very near and dear to me uh being
you know the religion so
you can also see the egyptian
hieroglyphs that are there
and he has a ton of switch outs which
make this statue
fantastic so you know
for a fact that um i'm crazy about this
statue
i really didn't think that i would get
it this is one of my holy grails
that will stay in my collection i love
the level of detail i love the fact that
he's crouching over
i love every aspect of this statue
because this is totally moon night
so this is the part of the video where
i'm gonna tell you
to like follow and subscribe and hit
that join button
hit that join button you know where that
join button is that join button is down
at the bottom
hit the join button so you can join the
room with iop
where it's sundays at 1pm
11am during football season oh boy this
football season is
killing me but that's why i am
so you can also catch episodes of kos
combat talk with the king last word with
lord cognito and ivantes
right now destiny is launched inside the
game pass
and if you're not looking at the last
word with low cognito and ibontes
and you have game pass i don't know what
you're doing but that's definitely
something that you need to be checking
out
man i can't wait for y'all to stick
around
and watch the rest of this stuff so you
can see the unboxing
you can listen to some nice music and
you can see the statue up close
so you can see him in all his glory
next week i have something
that is equally as spectacular
and is another holy grail that i got
from yours truly my man todd from spec
fix
spec fiction yeah it's just
that that word is crazy but spec fiction
is where you should be getting your
statues from
stay collected
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i ruled
[Music]
you